[Music]
um hello plastic pills listeners uh it's
just victor and i'm joined by
uh professor blake wilson
that's you do you go by blake right not
m i notice on a lot of your like faculty
page and i even remember when we first
met like you on your facebook you have m
before blake what's the deal with that
victor the m is for matthew or matt and
uh matt wilson is pretty vanilla
and it could be mark williams it could
be mike williams it could be mike wilson
etc but blake is my middle name
and i've always liked it so i've been
blake for decades
and the m is just a way to set uh
all of it apart but uh yeah that's for
matthew and the only person who calls me
that is my mother uh when i'm in trouble
fair enough fair enough flick yeah so
you know we first met actually
at the very first conference that i ever
went to which was at gonzaga university
in washington state it was the
gonzaga graduate philosophy conference
and i believe
and i remember being pretty nervous and
i don't know it'll be interesting to see
if your memory attracts with mine
but i remember seeing you you were
giving a presentation on maybe it was
nietzsche and some other stuff and you
were kind of walking around the room
giving a very impassioned reading of
your paper and i remember being so
nervous because i was like oh my god am
i gonna have to walk around and be
animated
um so yeah i don't know what do you
remember about that
well i certainly remember meeting you
and we've been friendly now for
oh i think that may have been six or
seven years ago
but yes that was a
philoso philosophy conference at gonzaga
and the reason why i did it and
participated was because
my niece was a junior
at gonzaga
so i hate to admit this but welcome to
the world of of academics
uh i participated in the in the
conference and flew
across the country
from new york to
washington
on my school's dime in order to
uh not so much
meet uh the conference with with
colleagues and present a paper but to
see my niece
yeah yeah right and i remember you know
i didn't know this about you at the time
but i mean it's in your bio right now
you teach at the department of criminal
justice at the california state
university i believe it's stannis laos
if that's how you pronounce it um
and but you are trained as a philosopher
right you're you're trained as a
philosopher and you have interests in
obviously legal theory legal studies
philosophy of law
applied ethics but your paper was
actually on nietzsche if i'm not
mistaken so you do also have
some interest in at least nietzsche and
maybe a broader continental thought as
well would you say that's true um
my connection to philosophy goes back to
middle school
and uh i was a big rock and roll fan
and i read a book called no one here
gets out alive which was a biography of
jim morrison of the doors
and uh
as i was becoming kind of an adolescent
turning into a teenager
i had read that morrison who i was very
fond of at the time less so now but
certainly earlier
i had been interested in philosophy and
particularly nietzsche
so i went to a local bookstore in a mall
to try to find a book
by this nietzsche and none were
available but i ordered one and it was
the portable nietzsche and penguin
edited by the great walter kaufman and i
think every teenage
you know
person interested in philosophy gets a
hold of some nietzsche and maybe gets a
hold of this book
i still have it
i've had to tape the cover on several
times but that got me interested in
philosophy so when i went to
college at san francisco state in the
mid-80s
i was a philosophy major and intended to
teach philosophy and write and research
and have the life of the academic
but
it it
struck me after a year or two of
undergraduate training
with some wonderful philosophers at san
francisco state
i thought it might be boring
and uh
i had been told like
lots of whatever you want to call it
precocious or
egotistical uh teenagers are told that
uh
who like to talk
oh you'd be a good lawyer
so i changed gears slightly i kept my
major in philosophy minored in pre-law
took a bunch of political science
courses went to law school in sacramento
the state capital of california
and then returned to san francisco and
practiced criminal defense law for many
years but the subtext with philosophy
is that i had always intended to get a
master's degree and teach
you know at a community college or teach
at night
to kind of satisfy the the thirst for
something a bit more intellectual than
the law
and i ended up earning the master's
degree in the late 2000s
and then began to teach at a community
college in boulder colorado
and i knew right then victor that
i was closing the door
on one chapter in my life which was the
lawyering and opening a new door which
was teaching but i knew i needed to get
the phd so
grades were you know mediocre i've never
been a very good student i've always
been more interested in action
uh test scores were okay
but i got a fully funded uh ta position
at binghamton with the state university
of new york
and it was there that uh you and i met
in
spokane
and i was there i think for
just
just barely over four years earning the
phd
it's pretty quick i taught for a year at
the coast guard academy
it was pretty quick i was motivated and
i already had the master's degree so it
shaved off that
that
couple years in the front
but my
wife and i we packed up and did a
one-year visiting assistant professor
gig at the coast guard academy which i
thought would be horrible but turned out
to be a fabulous experience
and it really paved the way for me to
get the job that i have now
as associate professor of
criminal justice which has allowed me to
blend together the kind of the legal
know-how with the more philosophical
uh uh
angle to it and they don't want me to
teach philosophy in my department the
philosophy department wants
philosophers to teach philosophy and the
criminal justice department wants
whatever criminal justice people to
teach
criminal justice but i do a little bit
of both
and so far it's been uh pretty
fulfilling
i made uh tenure after three and a half
years
uh again i was motivated and worked very
hard for it so
hopefully that's not too many words to
uh no no bring you up to no that's good
what i've been doing over the past
several years
it's great and you know i think i was a
little bit uh older when i started when
i went back to grad school and i think i
remember seeing
you know for for listeners aren't gonna
gonna see you but i remember i mean you
don't you look pretty good but but i
remember at the conference um
i was like oh this is this this guy's
like a little bit more of a mature
student i think you're i'm guessing you
were maybe in your 40s at the time uh
maybe that's wrong
um oh
i'm 55 now i'm 55 now so i began
my phd program
in 2012 nine years ago so i was i was 46
and the students in my career were two
of them were fresh out of undergrad
and the other three had mas and were a
bit older
but i would point out
that out of those six students
um
i'm the only one who's who's graduated
and not just graduated but got a
tenure-track job so i just want to say
it was a bit because i remember feeling
a little bit insecure about the fact
that i went started grad school maybe
five six years later than you were
supposed to remember meeting you and
then watching you
get a tenure track job you know it was
like a a a positive story and i was like
it is possible you know to go back and
and follow what you really believe in
and what you believe in doing so
i definitely appreciated that but i did
want to say
why i wanted to talk to you i guess and
you've you've told us a little bit about
your background
actually being a practicing uh criminal
attorney but then also having that
interest in philosophy
um and not just like the boring kind of
analytical philosophy of law but also
having some interest in nietzsche
and stuff like that and i think
i started thinking about you or thinking
about somebody at least i could talk to
um when all this stuff when all these
kind of high-profile cases that have
been happening recently
um
so i have in mind things like the kyle
rittenhouse case or the ahmad arbory
case
and it seemed like there's there was a
lot of symbolic meaning that people
invested in these cases
um especially when it came to the kyle
rittenhouse case you know i found myself
surrounded by what seemed like
almost a strong libidinal urge to
shoehorn the case into whatever
ideological narratives
um worked on either side right i mean
the right wanted written house uh to be
some kind of hero or symbol of freedom
um self-defense um and then the left
made it like you know white supremacy
itself was on trial um as if like the
not guilty verdict was evidence of white
supremacy so
you know that whole dynamic was really
interesting to me to watch and in fact i
saw a lot of really smart people that i
respect
have really kind of what seemed to me
very like thoughtless case thoughtless
takes on what was happening
um
and you know on this podcast i don't
know if i mentioned it but we we are
generally like like consider ourselves a
left-wing
podcast and you know i myself would say
i'm
pretty critical of the criminal justice
system in the states like i mean
everywhere i think
you know the urge to see someone
punished for something
is generally a kind of ugly human trait
you know the pitchfork mentality if you
will it kind of scares me
um
so
i guess that whole dynamic was really
interesting to me so it was i wanted to
talk to somebody who had practical
criminal justice experience but had a
philosophical perspective so i said a
lot of words there so i don't know if
you wanted to if you had any thoughts
about all that stuff that i said these
big trials lately i think you're
absolutely right they have disclosed
much like
many other events in american politics
a
very much an us versus them mentality
and um
it is as if your
your political posture
determined your prejudgment
of these high-profile cases
and uh that was certainly the case with
with written house
that the per the the the people who were
desirous
the as you say the libidinal
uh impulse uh desirous of a conviction
i think if we were to
conduct a poll
it would line up
directly one-to-one one-to-one ratio
with you know liberal democrats
and that those who were wishing for an
acquittal on self-defense grounds
uh would have been uh you know not right
wing
necessarily it would include every
right-wing
uh person but then less and less more
middle of the road you know republicans
and i think that's a shame um
as a defense attorney
i i take a a a sort of
uh um
idiosyncratic approach to the criminal
trial
i find myself hoping for an acquittal
in
all of these trials
it doesn't matter what they are and
here's how i've i've tried to understand
my own psychology
to me
i i always hope that these people didn't
do the horrible thing they're accused of
i hope kyle ridden house written house
didn't
go into kenosha with the intent of
murdering
peaceful liberal protesters and blm
and i hope that i don't know the names
of the defendants in the arbory case but
i hope
that those
men did not hunt down african this
african-american young man
and kill him in the way that depicted on
these videos
so you know you can imagine this leads
to some strange conversations where i
say i i hope he's innocent
or i hope they are innocent what i mean
is i hope that in the eyes of god or
whatever you want to call it they're
innocent not that a jury is swayed by
emotion or politics
but that they really didn't do it and
that the jury system
that the prosecutor is fair and just
that the defense lawyer is zealous in
their representation of the accused
and that the judge is fair and and not
biased towards the
prosecution which is what they usually
are
and that the jury is
you know was selected under the
constitutional principles of
impartiality
i always hope that that's you know
that that's what takes place at the
front end
and then at the back end the jury says
we find that you killers of ahmad arbori
did not murder this man
and that you written house did not
murder these people
why because i don't i don't want them to
be murderers i don't want anyone to be a
murderer
and
i don't or i try not to have the
prejudgment based upon
you know my politics which tend to be
kind of idiosyncratic as well i don't
align myself
i align myself definitely more with what
we call traditional american leftism
but i'm
pro-gun and pro-gun rights
so it doesn't fit in as neatly as we
would all
like our politics to fit in
i'm wondering what you think about
you know i guess how do you see the
criminal justice system fitting into
broader concerns about systematic
injustice as kind of the term is used
right because i think what was
interesting about some of these cases is
the way
these systematic problems
were almost put on trial like
symbolically in people's imaginations
and i guess to what extent do you see as
both a philosopher and as as uh you know
someone with experience being a criminal
defense attorney
like where does that fit in does it fit
in is it even like talking about the
same thing or should we be looking
somewhere else for
solutions to questions of systematic
injustice
well that's certainly been the the uh
rallying cry over the past several years
is the uh recognition of uh what we've
now come to call
you know systematic racism in the
criminal justice system
and uh
that is what uh
uh critical legal or critical race
theory teaches um
uh which is the idea that a
racist system
you know doesn't need any living actual
racists in it
and um
that's an in we could maybe talk about
that
if you want to it's kind of a hot button
topic
but certainly the criminal justice
system
has
uh elements of
systemic or institutional
racism
i believe it's mostly tied into issues
related to
wealth and class
and not as much uh race
which is where you might make a
distinction between
uh crt and some other theories about uh
justice
but um
[Music]
what we've seen with some of these
trials is
when somebody like rittenhouse is
acquitted
uh you know rittenhouse didn't kill uh
african-americans he didn't kill any
minorities he's not a police officer
but the way that the left reacted with
this was that this is you know the
racist system has said it's a green
light on killing you know liberals
liberal supporters of
equal rights and racial justice
and then what two weeks later
the killers of the mod arbory not police
are uh are convicted
so you can't have
if structural racism is true to the
extent
that many people uh claim it is true
then you cannot have a conviction in a
mod arbories case
the structure would prevent it
so and that may be kind of a fine you
know finely grained point to uh
to argue
but if there is
the the the systemic racism
to the extent that many people believe
it to
exist
then the convictions like in the arbory
case would be impossible and that's
clearly
clearly
not the case
and so it leaves
it leaves critics like us in an
interesting position
you know what is there to be critical of
when the killers of ahmad arbory are are
convicted
or when there are other
convictions like
derek chovin in the george floyd case
so there's another situation where
it's you know we could set up we
you and i at our conference years ago we
uh
i remember talking to don eyed about
logic crunchers
and it's a term that i've used you know
over the years i learned it from don
and i love the term and what it means is
you know you could set up a line by line
uh schematic argument
about you know a variety of
controversial topics and in this one we
could set it up to say something like if
structural racism exists
then convictions in cases
like
derek chovin at all is impossible well
the convictions are possible and then
you could work out the argument so
there is a
a deep and invasive
racial and class and
income
injustice in the cj system but whether
or not it's as pervasive
is you know another question you know
one of the allegations that uh
michelle alexander put forth in her you
know excellent book
uh the new jim crow yeah is that the war
on drugs was a racially motivated war
racially it was a racially motivated war
and uh
that the war on drugs is really the
fourth
you know institution in white supremacy
the first being slavery the second being
uh
the jim crow laws
the third being the ghetto
and the ghettoization of of
african-american neighborhoods and the
fourth being uh the prison
and uh
you know here's another way where i'm
not i'm not toeing the line necessarily
to some of the party uh uh politics but
um you know the war on drugs and the
amount of people who are imprisoned for
drugs in the united states is far less
than somebody like alexander
or other theorists
or propagandists whatever you want to
call it um
the amount of people in prison for drugs
is
far less than most people believe oh
really
and
the i oh far less so
you know we have two we have well we
have
53 prison systems in the u.s so there's
one for every state there's a federal uh
justice system and then a military one
so if we leave out the military the
federal prisons are in fact
filled with about 50
narcotics offenders dealers
manufacturers methamphetamine
importers etc
but the number of people in the federal
prisons is only about eight or nine
percent of the total population of
people in prison
the vast majority of people in prison
are in state prisons like california's
got 2.3 million people in prison
and they are there not for drugs drugs
only account for 10 or 15 percent
of
of
prisoners doing time in the state
prisons the rest of them are doing time
for good old traditional crimes like
violent property crimes and assaults and
weapons weapons crimes
so the argument that the war on drugs
was implemented to
you know maintain white supremacy i
think has a lot of holes in it there's
certainly elements of it but
that argument does not account for the
reasons why
there's disproportionate numbers of
african-american young men
in prisons in the form of what we call
uh you know mass incarceration
so even here's the point victor even if
we were to as a society legalize
drugs and let everybody out of prison
we're still we're looking at a a dip in
the total prison population of maybe
five or ten percent
so therefore once again here we are
chopping the logic
uh the war on drugs is not the cause of
mass incarceration
and the the sort of uh you know
mechanistic schematic
uh
releasing of all drug prisoners
uh doesn't fix the problem of mass
incarceration
right
yeah and i think that's an uh i think
one of the examples that's usually
brought up from that michelle alexander
book is
the whole differential sentencing
between crack and coke and regular
powder cocaine right because um
i guess black people disproportionately
use crack cocaine and white people tend
to use powder cocaine so but that's i
guess your point is like yeah there
might be some
kind of elements of that that fit into
the narrative but it doesn't really
explain everything as a cohesive theory
of like why the criminal justice system
is the way it is why there's mass
incarceration um but do you see um
mass incarceration i guess as a hu as a
big problem because it is pretty
astounding when you look at the stats
you compare to other developed countries
it's like the per capita population in
prison is
is is huge so do you see that as maybe
not reducible to racism obviously but
some other issue with the united states
what's going on do you think with that
oh absolutely
the number of people in cages in this
country is
shameful absolutely shameful
and
i have a book hopefully coming out soon
called a philosophy of criminal justice
and
one of the issues that i research and
argue
is
is the arrest
and the the
incapacitation and incarceration of
individuals
and so what i'm working on
what i'm exploring is what justifies the
arrest what what is an individual and we
can really abstract this one out we
could really put on the philosopher's
cap here
cool you know what sorts of conditions
must be met in order to justify
physically you know restraining somebody
and putting them
in a cage
and that's how i like to frame the
arrest
and
where i teach many of my students want
to be police officers
and men some of them want to be lawyers
and i tend to gravitate towards the
students that want to be lawyers or
court personnel
uh i'm involved in our our major just
for what it's worth our criminal justice
major
you have to pick a concentration and so
i'm part of our criminal legal studies
concentration
and i teach courses in
jury selection evidence legal research
and writing death penalty mood court
classes like that
but with all my students
and when i teach the more general
courses i teach a criminal procedure
course which is
you know the constitutional
decisions by the supreme court regarding
fourth amendment search and seizure
fifth amendment right to counsel sixth
amendment uh right to trial seventh
amendment uh
i don't think we do the seventh eighth
amendment cruel unusual punishment
but what i keep coming back to
with my students and what i'm trying to
address in this book because i think
it's severely under addressed
is what conditions must be met where we
can say it is just fair
equitable etc to physically
you know incapacitate a person through
the use of force
and through the use of incapacitation in
the form of incarceration
and that's a question that we haven't
asked
because it's a matter of routine
especially my students you know we live
in
in
our schools located in very rural
environment in california central valley
a lot of the students are
we're a minority majority institution
65 to 70 percent
mexican-american hispanic american
latino latinx whatever you want to call
it
and many of these are first jet first
gen students
and so
their parents maybe work in the fields
or work at many of the meat and poultry
processing plants that we have
in many ways the area where the school
is located is more like the midwest or
parts of the south than it is
then it resembles what we think of as
california
but anyway my point is
for many students
on the first day of class when i ask why
are you majoring in criminal justice
and they say well i grew up
you know right down the road they might
mention a town
that
is uh you know somewhat impoverished
with
uh
substandard uh
institut a substandard
um infrastructure in terms of education
health water
etc
but many of them victor you'll find this
interesting they say well
the police were not respected in my
community
and uh
and they were biased towards us
and that's a sad thing to hear
where
uh
you know we have these beliefs perhaps
about police and racism and the the blue
wall of silence and so forth and then
you hear kids 18 year old kids
you know coming to college for the first
time and saying well that's what i
experienced growing up i didn't
experience that as a white middle-class
kid growing up down in southern
california
but the students many of them will say
well i want to i say well why do you
want to be a you know what do you want
to do when you grow up i want to be a
cop professor wilson
and i said why do you want to be a cop
that you say well i want to go back to
my community and be that be what the cop
is supposed to be a member of the
community that protects people from
you know violence and answers calls for
you know safety or assistance and so
forth so they've there's some noble
noble uh
uh goals noble aspirations
but my question always comes back to
them what what is it that justifies
you know laying hands on another person
to
you know to to incapacitate them
and for many of them victor they just
never thought of it
and i think most people don't think of
it and most people tend to think well if
the law prohibits it
and that's very much what we call a
positivist
approach to something like criminal
justice
you and i get together we're a lawful
legislature
we pass a series of general laws what uh
hart uh hla hart the great
legal positivist uh
legal philosopher of law
we get together and we have a justly
created constitution which provides our
primary rules
about our culture and then we make up a
bunch of secondary rules based on the
primary rules and the secondary rules
would be things like don't spit on the
sidewalk
or you know don't eat high caloric food
or
you know don't
put marijuana in your body or something
like that
so the positive approach tends to be
if the law has been legitimately created
and it outlaws some sort of behavior
well then an arrest would be justified
because there's evidence that a person
has
transgressed or violated that law it's
been witnessed to an extent by police or
witnesses
and there's a series of procedures or
rules
that determine how punishment is then to
be uh meted out
and i think that's the wrong way to look
at it that's looking at it from a purely
procedural point of view and not from a
substantive point of view
so what i'm working on in this book and
again something i bring up with students
is what sorts of behavior what does a
person need to do to get put into the
slam the slam of course be you know jail
and
and what i'm working on is the idea that
the police have no special claim
towards the use of force or
incapacitation against an individual
and that any individual
as long as they are justified in using
that force against another individual to
incapacitate them tie them up
put them into a little box kill them etc
that the police are then as justified as
any other person
acting to incapacitate that individual
so it really takes the
the police
uh almost out of the picture in terms of
the justification for the arrest
that's interesting
that almost sounds like there's an
implicit kind of
libertarian argument there i mean i
could be wrong but
it reminds me structurally of
the kind of question that some
libertarians ask which is like what
gives the government like what justifies
the government's
use of force in general like broadly
like what gives what justifies state
power which is
almost a question about
the kind of default intuitions we have
which is like why is our default that
they are allowed right like shouldn't
the default be that they're not allowed
in a way i don't know um
to what extent do you think that that
argument is kind of libertarian if or
maybe that's not a helpful category here
well
i i don't like that term uh i get
accused of that occasionally and only
recently as it really turned into
a
derogatory term
uh
libertarian sure yeah i don't mean it
derogatorily by the way yeah well
libertarians have been characterized
recently as this sort of warped form of
ultra right wingism which i don't think
is the case at all but that's you know
that's just political
uh uh you know
definition yeah that's just political
rhetoric not actual philosophy right
so
uh you could you could definitely trace
back
what i've been talking about to
more basic ideas about
government power and the right of the
state
so if you look at somebody like nozick
here we are talking about libertarianism
and um
you know nozick
knows its basic argument in anarchy
state and utopia he's obviously not
arguing for anarchy he's arguing for
this type of various utopias
he goes back to the lockheed state of
nature
and that ultimately these uh
the rights that are the ultimate right
that is that issue is a property right
in one's person
and i've looked into that and i
i i've rejected that
but it's worth it's worth to it's worth
discussing it because it's a very
popular idea
that uh individuals began
at conception
with a a a right
of
self-ownership
and that uh you know it comes from god
or whomever
and uh
that that is an integral part of you
know one's human right it may be your
only human right
is that you own yourself
and that when individuals harm you they
harm your property which is your body
and when you wander out into that
wonderful desert island
as robinson crusoe
uh in these situations that political
philosophers love to create
um
when you wander out into that desert
island unowned and unoccupied
after you've been shipwrecked well the
coconuts you collect and the bananas you
collect and the
uh
the little uh uh tent or whatever that
you build with your coconut husks why
that's yours well why is it yours
because nobody owned it before you
and you mixed your labor
sure your which you own with stuff that
nobody owns and it becomes yours i
reject that uh yeah
as
for a variety of different reasons
but it's a hand it's a very handy way to
at least come up with a grounding
uh to think about what's wrong with
somebody harming another person
and so it's a fairly easy way to
describe the this very basic idea of
rights and self-ownership and it's an
easy way to explain what's wrong with
hitting somebody over the head with a
stick
and taking their coconut
yeah it's an easily encapsulated uh
theory which is probably why it appeals
to you know maybe a lot of freshmen
and ein rand readers uh yeah as well
well the one the one person that i was
thinking of actually i don't know if
you've heard of him he's more of an
analytic philosopher michael humer
i i saw him give a talk once on online
and he sort of
he framed
his question about
the state what gives the state the
justification to for example like tax
you
um
he looks at it from more the perspective
of
well i just haven't heard any arguments
that are that convincing that tell me
that they do have that power yeah as
opposed to like having some sort of like
ideal like he's very much only
interested in like arguments that are
convincing like he's one of those
typical kind of analytic philosophy
types
and he doesn't have really any sort of
ideological commitments he's just
interested in the arguments and for him
he's like well i just haven't heard any
arguments that are convincing to me of
like why
the government gets this
this this power to do that and kind of
like your argument about police i mean i
don't know you haven't gone through the
arguments obviously but
you kind of just say that you the kind
of
story you're developing
leads you to the conclusion that it
doesn't actually seem like the police do
have or there's not at least convincing
reasons you've heard for why they should
be given that maybe that's a
misinterpretation but that's kind of
what i was hearing
well humor's book the problem of
political authority is a wonderful book
okay so you know it yeah and he
published oh very well he published that
around the same time uh
that david boonen whose humor's
colleague at university of colorado at
boulder
published a book called the problem of
punishment
and
they both addressed the idea
and this is kind of where the the the
the problem of the arrest is really
predicated on the problem of of
punishment
uh
so what humor argues is and i think
you're right you've characterized it
pretty well there's no good argument
that justifies the power authority of
the state and he walks through all of
them and says why they failed
so david boonett does the same thing in
his book the problem of punishment
which has had an enormous influence on
me particularly coming out of a long
career
in the the punishment industry for life
the better word as a person as a defense
attorney trying to minimize
as much punishment as possible for those
that i'm i was you know
uh charged with uh defending and
assisting with their legal
uh infirmities
for lack of a better word
but here's what bonin argues about
punishment and i i think this is a good
argument boonen walks through all those
good old-fashioned justifications
utilitarian justification
deontic or deontological justification
for punishment we punish you because you
deserve it and we are socially obligated
to punish you when you do a bad thing
uh you know kant spelled it out better
than anybody maybe not uh in terms of
clarity but the the gist of the uh in
clarity of writing certainly clarity of
conception uh kant uh can't be beat for
his justification of uh punishment based
upon his categorical imperatives
um
but what boonen does victor is boone
walks through each one of these
and he says
ultimately
in the end
when a
society punishes an individual
they are harming them on
purpose and there is no moral or ethical
justification to purposefully
harm somebody in the way that people are
harmed when they're punished
so
and this is a part of i'm using this in
in my in my book
and i i i'm essentially an abolitionist
so
yeah my so my
my
yeah yeah and uh boy when you talk about
practical problems with your with your
uh larger uh ideals
uh you know an abolitionist uh believes
that the criminal justice system or the
prison system ought to be abolished
so that immediately right there's red
flags yellow flags you name it all the
flags start popping up
but the gist of the idea really can be
uh found in this wonderful book problem
of punishment by david boone
what boonen says is we already have a
system of justice our civil system of
justice
and
what that is predicated upon
is
uh restitution
uh payback and i know that payback might
not be the best word because it sounds
like you know the the law of the streets
or something like that but maybe in a
way that's eye for an eye well
uh yeah and you know what's interesting
about eye for an eye is an eye for an
eye and the old testament was meant as a
limiting
principle we think of it today as sort
of this barbaric justice if somebody
pops your eye out well you get to pop
his out well previous to that
and previous to the you know the the
the the creation of jewish morality
uh you know well before the socratics
and so forth if somebody popped your eye
out you killed them
and so what an eye for an eye means is
no there's there's a parody here and so
you are permitted to repay
or
commit an act of retribution retribute
is simply tribute is to give and
retribute is to give back
so if somebody wrongs you you get back
what they've taken from you
and not more so an eye for an eye really
is not quite it's not as barbaric as
what existed
before historically
but the idea that the boone works on and
that i'm i'm uh
trying to steal from him as much as
possible partly because i think there's
great intuitive appeal to it
is that when a person
is harmed by another person
we as a society have become focused on
the punishment of the wrongdoer and not
the re
the compensation or the restitution
of the victim
and
our civil system strives to do that
if somebody you know is negligent they
back their car into you and you break
your arm and you're out of work for a
month and they smash up your car well if
you use the court system or the uh you
know the pre-court negotiation system
what do you have a right to well you
have a right to your expenses and and
you have a right to your pain and
suffering and
you know
and
societies have have long
uh
uh facilitated conflict resolution in
that way
it's that urge to punish the wrongdoer
is a criminal that i have a problem with
and it's the the bifurcation of a system
of justice
into civil and criminal
uh categories and structures and
institutions
that i think was the wrong move
now we look back at the the you know
every
i was just going to look back every
freshman philosophy students
every every freshman philosophy student
reads plato's apology
and uh you know without telling the
whole story
socrates uh kind of the jon stewart
maybe of his
of his uh
city state of athens in
what four
[Music]
twenty
trying to get my dates right here
i think it's like three something maybe
it's four fourths
yeah um i know he's 72 when he dies oh
i'm sorry i gave away the the ending
anyway socrates of course ran a foul of
some
some some people in power in his
community
and there was no government per se
to charge socrates with a crime that it
didn't exist at the time
and so uh a a lawsuit a graph a it's
called was filed against socrates for
corrupting the youth and for
[Music]
impiety for preaching these existence of
gods other than the gods of the official
roman or greek civil religion
and he was put on trial and they had
jury duty just like we have jury duty
today
the case was presented against him he
presented his case and it's remarkable
how similar this is to
how we have trials today
uh he was convicted and then the issue
of punishment
arose
and that also tracks our current
america united states practice in the
death penalty meaning a single jury
hears evidence of guilt
and then they if they find the defendant
guilty they then
review evidence related to the
punishment and that's really the only
time juries take part in punishment
decisions in the american jury trial
system but anyway as you know um
socrates then sort of shot his mouth off
and when he was offered the chance to
uh uh explain
justify a punishment he could have left
he could have gone into exile
or he could have paid a fine i think he
offered to pay something like seven mina
which was about 10 bucks
but instead he asked for meals for life
in the hall of heroes and of course the
jury said thumbs down and he was
uh convicted and he was
sentenced you know to death and he died
by the horrible cup of poison hemlock
but my point what's my point
my point is that that is 2500 years old
and is evidence of a almost purely civil
ju there was no justice of course
in the abstract in the case of socrates
but the idea was these were private
citizens bringing a case before a
tribunal
and seeking a particular outcome
and then somewhere along the line this
bifurcation occurs between
a civil justice system which are private
parties battling it out
and a true criminal justice system
with an a
remarkable matrix of interrelated
institutions
who legislate and criminalize
criminalize
legislatures obviously do that and
occasionally the people do that sort of
thing as well
and then a prosecutorial arm is created
who investigate and prosecute
uh there's a defense uh
institution as well
where defendants are granted certain
rights not granted others there's a
judicial system that is supposedly
neutral and and uh the intermediate is
an intermediary between the two parties
and then ultimately if there's a finding
of guilt there's a punishment that is uh
usually uh implemented by uh the judge
uh
based on
a punishment scheme decided by the
legislature
then there's a whole other institution
of you know houses of correction and
jails and prisons and probation and
parole
in halfway houses and restrictions on
voting rights and gun ownership
so
the cj you know i teach criminal justice
but on the first day of class when i ask
what justifies an arrest i also want
them to make sure they understand
the enormity
of the
larger institute there's no single
institution of criminal justice in this
country
however in many ways i would argue that
there is roughly
a much more
streamlined
system of civil justice
which requires interestingly enough
compare this with a criminal law
a civil
justice case victor
requires not only that an individual was
harmed
but they can prove their damages
that there's an actual
victim or person who's been harmed
and that they have uh
they have a need for compensation
well the criminal justice system i
suppose is intended to do that but
there's nothing at least in the american
criminal justice system that requires
there to be a victim look at drug laws
or status offenses fell into possession
of a firearm
or that there's been any actual you know
wrongdoing done
and that from by that i mean again
things like status offenses and so forth
so if a criminal justice system is meant
to protect innocent
individuals victims from harm unjust
harm i think that's important because i
could certainly harm you and it wouldn't
be unjust and it wouldn't be you know
cause for the system let's say you're
running victor's
you know
food truck
down on broadway and you got a great
business and you're selling
uh
do you know what carnitas are
yeah yeah
yeah the fried uh pork
well the carnitas taco is one of my
favorite i don't eat pork
but when i did i would have killed for a
good carnitas taco so let's say victor
runs victor's carnitas and i open up a
food cart across the street
and mine are better
and it puts you out of business so have
you been harmed by my action yes is it
unjust absolutely not
let's say i harmed you by sneaking you
know ipecac you know it's stuff that
makes people sick into your carnitas
well that would be unjust and then you
know we'd need to resolve that
but um
what our criminal justice system has
done
is
we have
we have taken away conflict and harm
we've taken away the the right to sue
from individuals and given it to our uh
the state
and there's a ton of different reasons
for it and there are our buddy lock that
we talked about earlier
in his great work the two treatises
nobody reads the first one but in the
second treatise he
he justifies punishment
uh by or
or police type actions which you had
mentioned a little bit earlier
on the grounds that you know any
individual who if any individual has the
right to punish another one
they can uh give that by proxy to
uh you know the person who is who's uh
uh the the governing local governing
body
yeah and the idea would be that if an
individual has been wronged they will
not
implement justice well they will want to
go beyond an eye for an eye
uh that it's good to have experts in
this sort of thing judges and lawyers
uh uh etc
so there may be
some
you know good reasons um
to take away an individual's
right to pursue justice against another
individual and transfer it to the state
um
but i think we've experimented with it
it's been the
the uh
the mode uh the style
uh the the institutional framework for
uh the state at least since the
industrial revolution
uh and we've predicated a huge part of
the state on the creation of
institutions
which seek to implement
justice not on behalf of a victim
but on behalf of society
and based on the idea that when an
individual harms another individual
to the extent that we call it a crime uh
just to find some type of punishment but
it's really not the individual who's
been harmed but it's society and i think
that's incorrect
i yeah i uh
i don't think that that's the right way
to frame this sort of thing
so we look at something like rittenhouse
and the killers of the mod arbory which
is what we began talking about
and uh
i'm forced to reconcile that uh
the type of system that i described
would have required the victims in
rittenhouse's case to
sue him for compensation
on the grounds
that he's done you know wrong to them to
their survivors to their family
uh etc
and that the state has no role
in
stepping in
as the you know senior interested party
in prosecuting somebody like rittenhouse
or even the the killers of the mod
arbory
by basically taking away
the wrongness of their actions the
wrongfulness of their actions
from the victims in that case yeah i
know that sounds really interesting i
mean i think there's a lot in what you
said there and one of the things i'm
interested in is um
you know this bifurcation i guess it's
something i hadn't really ever thought
about um that that there was like a
split between civil law where private
parties would would try to like you know
correct for wrongs as opposed to this
this thing then i you know i was there i
had a lot of thoughts when you were
talking there and one of them was kind
of remembering you know hegel i think in
the philosophy of right also it makes
this argument about why the state needs
to be the one that um that is somehow
this impartial
or that that that because as the state
is like the embodiment of
um
of like you know human consciousness
developing it needs to be the arbiter
for for correcting for certain wrong so
that that's that's all really
interesting but you know my perspective
on kind of abolition
you know has a little bit more less to
do with kind of those
abstract philosophical justifications
which i think i mean i'm sympathetic i
agree and more just sort of the
empirical question which just seems to
be that the criminal justice system
doesn't really seem to make society that
much safer right like it seems
to actually
sometimes reinforce criminality prisons
seem to reinforce criminality
um and and we don't really see the
fruits of all that money and and you
know violation of people's rights and
and the the taking away of their freedom
it doesn't seem like we're getting that
much in return as a society right um
so i don't know what you think about
that kind of question the sort of
empirical question about
you know what is it for right like
justice i mean you when you were talking
about the civil justice system it's i
guess in some ways to correct wrongs
but then the criminal justice system
is sort of for that
but like what are we actually getting
for it in ter like in terms of
societal outcomes that we would probably
prefer right it doesn't seem to be
delivering that much
well in many ways it's purely
utilitarian
purely utilitarian we have an individual
who has broken a law
and
there's a you get a lot more goodies by
putting that p per individual in jail
and having them lose out on their
goodies
but the rest of us get a bunch of
goodies out of it we get a we get we get
feelings of pleasure the the libido this
urge i forget what you said called it
earlier yeah yeah there's a real urge
there's a real urge to
kind of uh
uh
see
individuals be punished and be harmed
and it's kind of a sick
you know element in our personality
um
we started this off talking about
nietzsche
and
his genealogy of morality from 18 i
think 86
is really one of the most cogent i think
it's the second book second essay one of
the most cogent discussions
of punishment
and institutional punishment that i've
ever read
and you know foucault picked it up in
the 70s when foucault was researching uh
the birth of the prison
uh discipline and punish um and the
wonderful lectures if you've ever if
you've ever read and i teach discipline
and punish
just about every class i'm not saying i
agree with all of it but it is so
thought-provoking
um
you know foucault
foucault wasn't really a historian
although i think his chair at the
college of paris was something like
chair of the history of ideas or
something i forget the name of it it
says he got to make it up you know when
he got his his chair
uh
but um
foucault lifted a lot of these ideas
from uh from nietzsche and what
nietzsche says is
you know why do we punish
any why do we even do this anymore
why do we engage in harmful actions to
people who do things that we don't like
and he walks through each one he gives
about 11 of these different
justifications
and it's sort of the philosopher's
you know process of elimination where at
the end of it nietzsche says we really
don't know why
and what's so interesting about
nietzsche in my book i actually
end up with kind of a nietzschean
influence deeply influenced
idea about uh punishment and justice and
restitution and so forth
and my reading of nietzsche
is that you know nietzsche was watching
the era that so fascinated foucault
foucault was fascinated and all of his
books are the same right gee
something happened around 1800 where we
move from
you know sort of this ragtag uh
uh decentralized states uh and then
suddenly we've got factories belching
out smoke and suddenly we have prisons
right and everything's a prison and the
barracks is a prison and the hospital is
a prison and they all look the same
um
and so that's obviously a pretty
fascinating observation but historically
you know uh the u.s begins with
different uh prison construction styles
right at the turn of the century
foucault is correct we really didn't
have or not we i hate saying that
prisons didn't exist prior to
the turn of the century in the way that
we think of them in western societies
punishment was quick it was swift you
may have
been unfortunate enough to sit in a jail
holding facility until your fate was
determined
but incarceration in a little metal cage
in a prison with a bunch of other people
incarcerated in cages
simply didn't exist on any wide scale as
a matter of fact and foucault points us
out it was almost considered kind of
inhumane
that a person would not would be
punished by losing their freedom so of
course punishment was purely corporal
and uh right it was swift it was public
and usually for you know felonies it was
uh capital it was the death penalty
so foucault is
correct to a to a large extent that this
change occurs and the first prisons were
built in upstate new york and auburn and
in philadelphia
and these were large buildings where you
put bad people in in order to give them
a little uh uh
cooling time a little time out to time
out what they've done and then they're
yeah they give a timeout and then
they're released back uh into society
under increasing forms of surveillance
and supervision in the forms of
probation and parole but what nietzsche
observed
is that this came to germany last
it america england france all of the you
know whatever you want to call them
civilized european nations
all within 30 years victor
transitioned from
public corporal punishment to private
non-corporal punishment
meaning
you're not beaten you're not whipped
matter of fact we don't even touch you
right we just put you in a in an
institution
so nietzsche observed that germany was
one of the last ones to start adopting
uh this style
and um
and he
uh
you know observed that this trend and
this again where foucault got a lot of
this
but he thought that this transition
was a form of this uh sort of what you
would have called progressive liberal
christian morality that of course
nietzsche
rejects
you know from the beginning to the slave
morality
yeah from the beginning his first breath
to his last
breath as the same person on january 3rd
1889
and of course he dies 11 years later as
a you know
a complete envelope
but my point is what nietzsche observed
yeah what's funny oh go ahead
well what nietzsche observed was
that it was now the state
that was claiming
an authority to seek
uh uh uh you know justice against
wrongdoers
and nietzsche was you know highly
critical of this because he saw it as
you know a form of revenge
and this is controversial in nietzsche's
studies but you know i think nietzsche
believed that individuals had this sort
of
had a a a responsibility
to stand up to their oppressors
especially with a pet somebody who still
you know this is a bad example maybe but
someone who steals a person's purse and
runs off
well that person needs to stand up to
them maybe they've been apprehended they
need to tell them you've harmed me and
you've taken my possessions or is
something much more serious like you
know physical assault or or sexual
assault and so forth
so nietzsche seemed
to very much believe that individuals
had almost an obligation
to face
their their their uh those who have uh
committed wrongful acts against them
and show them they're afraid
that's interesting um
you know what's kind of ironic i guess
about that transition
to morse i guess uh slave morality
approach to punishment right is of
course it was supposed to be more humane
but i think as we've sort of come to see
uh the results actually end up being
quite inhumane um and you know there's
an interesting philosopher who actually
i met her once um lisa gunther you might
be familiar with her work she wrote uh a
phenomenological account of uh solitary
confinement right and kind of gives an
account of how it's it ends up being a
form of social death uh where they're
kind of like reality you know like uh
kind of shrinks into this like sphere
where there's there's no
hope uh in a way so i think we we see
these results uh that they don't give us
um they don't end up being as humane as
i guess was originally expected and
there's another person you might be
familiar with his work peter moscos i
think he wrote an interesting book
called in defense of flogging
where he kind of makes this argument
that uh you know it's our system is so
bad you know it's so inhumane
that it would actually be better
as one of partial temporary solution to
mass incarceration
that we ought to give people the option
that you know if they get charged with
something maybe we should tell them okay
you could go to prison for five years or
how about 10 lashings
uh and then you're just out the door and
you're gone uh and it's like because
he's like why are we pretending
that what we're doing is so humane we
may as well just give people the option
to be flogged because this is so
ridiculous uh i don't know if you're
familiar with his work but if you are
aren't i'd be curious what your thoughts
are on that kind of argument
i'm familiar with the the gist of the
book and i remember looking it up when
it came out a few years ago and was
surprised that the title was not a
satire
he was
he was serious
years ago years ago when i was
practicing criminal
defense and i read foucault in my senior
year of of college in 1989 in a class
called hegel marx foucault and read
discipline and punish
and got it you know right away
and then
went to law school and then was found
myself
in san quentin prison representing
lifers people doing life best serving
life sentences
and uh try representing them during
their parole hearings these are people
who have done horrible things
but my point with
with the
the question about something like
flogging once i began to represent
people
ranging from minor marijuana offenses to
first-degree murder and sexual assault
and i conducted a little experiment a
couple times and asked
you have your choice
let's say
you go to prison for five years or
we put you in a room uh with the the
state uh
you know i don't know what you call this
person the punisher
like the cartoon the comic book
character
yeah and they're gonna beat the crap out
of you and do horrible things to you and
which would you prefer and to a t they
all said
you know i'll take what's behind door
number door number three
to a t
so it's almost like the creation of the
the system of incarceration
uh that there was a conscientious
um
a conscious part of the creation of the
institution that knew
that this is worse
than the old-fashioned system and you
can imagine victor you're at the
cocktail party and you're saying you
know the old-fashioned system of putting
somebody in the stocks out in the
village square and throwing
rotten fruit at them that was actually
more more just
than putting somebody in a little room
and keeping track of them and testing
their urine for a year after they get
out and restricting their freedom and
their voting rights it's more honest
well
well um i think nietzsche again really
had his finger on that in the 1880s and
foucault picked up on it uh quite a bit
as well
what's also really interesting um
about somebody like foucault is there's
a number of different scholars
who
[Music]
who did a little bit more historical
research
into the creation of the prisons
and put a long story short
you know determined that the motivation
for much of it really was
uh
humanitarian
and that on many levels foucault was
simply wrong
historically about the creation of the
prison
as a you know offshoot of the industrial
revolution
of the idea that you can't hack a guy's
arm off because then he can't pull a
switch you know in a in in a factory
owned by the resident capitalist or
something like that so fuco's got
there's a lot of problems with foucault
but you know the the idea i think of
philosophy isn't necessarily to be right
but it's to inspire
uh thinking and speculation not just
about the stars uh beyond but the soul
within
and especially the the institutions that
kind of sit as a halfway point
between our
you know our our inner
inner selves and then the the mysteries
of of uh of the universe yeah i guess
the one the one question i have which
kind of circles back to just
the written house case and i guess this
idea of
um
reasonable doubt uh and
and innocent until proven guilty the
assumption of innocence which obviously
so earlier you were talking about the
split between the civil system versus
the criminal system and in the civil
system as much to my understanding the
bar for proving your case is lower right
it's like um it's something like uh more
likely than not
versus beyond a reasonable doubt
and the reason i'm bringing this up is
just because
uh you know when people were angry about
the written house verdict
what it seemed to me that a lot of them
really don't understand
the difference between or what exactly
it means for something to be beyond a
reasonable doubt
um and then just sort of the
philosophical question that you know
even though i think i agree with you i'm
convinced that the criminal system ought
to probably be abolished
but you know if we're gonna have a
criminal system i guess the idea of
assuming that someone's innocent until
proven guilty and that you have to prove
beyond a reasonable doubt
um is a probably a good thing at least
justified the idea being that you know
the possibility of convicting an
innocent person is just so great
that we have to assume that people now
it doesn't work in practice but i guess
i was wondering if you had thoughts
about that that that question and sort
of the misunderstandings around what
that means exactly well looking at it as
a constitutional theorist slash lawyer
you know there's nothing in the
constitution that describes these
standards of either guilt in a criminal
case beyond a reasonable doubt or
liability in a civil case which is by a
preponderance
of the evidence and another way of
saying it is just what you said more
likely or not
so you're in the parking lot somebody is
squealing out on the ice they smash into
you you get hurt you sue them you know
they said i didn't do anything wrong it
was the ice and the maintenance people
there at university of toronto are
responsible etc
anyway you sue them and i'm going to
assume it's the same in the great white
north i don't know it for a fact but i'm
going to assume it's the same because it
is
yeah
the standard of proof which means what a
person must prove in a court of law in
order to
have the defendant
found liable is the preponderance of the
evidence
so how is that explained well this is
something that you hear in law school
and then you hear it in
the civil courts of the united states
the plaintiff must prove their case and
i always do this when i explain it
victor and the folks who are listening
can imagine i put my arms straight out
so
juries are told that the plaintiff
victor must prove his case
by a preponderance of the evidence which
means 50 percent plus
and it's a word i've never heard before
and i don't think i'll ever hear again
except in this context
50 plus a cintilla
s-c-i-n-t-i-l-l-a
a scintilla
and what did that mean it's what my
mother would have called a skosh
what it means is anything over 50
percent
so you prove anything over 50 more
likely than not preponderance of the
evidence
and you win
now
that's
no matter what right we can you you
imagine you're on a jury and you're told
that you can kind of hash it out you can
almost put up you know the witnesses for
the plaintiff the witnesses for the
defendant and you say this witness
wasn't credible
and you the jury might end up saying god
it's overwhelmingly the case that
they're liable or if you get down to the
brass tax it might be just that victor
has a cintilla
cintilla and i love teaching this and
saying this to students and i tell them
you'll never hear this word again
cintilla and write it on the board as
big as possible
and you know that you know that uh for a
fact finder and juries of course you
know act as these
these you know epistemic agents they are
they are tasked
with determining
uh truth they are tasked with recreating
facts that occurred in the past and
determining who's telling the truth
that's really what they're what they're
doing
so uh there's that you know huge
epistemological element
in uh the the jury trial process and in
the law of course uh as well
um
and the question would be
you know what's true and why why should
i believe that the certain facts you
know existed
but in the criminal cases you mentioned
a criminal case it's required
constitutionally although that's because
the supreme court has said it and not
because it's anywhere in the
constitution
that guilt of a defendant it's
interesting in the civil and criminal
case
the bad guy the person who's being
either sued by a civil plaintiff or
being sued
it's kind of the same there's a
corollary
uh being sued by the state we call them
a defendant but in the civil case we
call them a plaintiff and in the
criminal case we call it the people or
the prosecution
the process or the crimes guilt not
liability
yeah that's right the regina is that the
word that they use i think they just say
that well everyone just talks about it
as the crown
right the crowns case the uh
yeah the the well the standard of proof
is beyond a reasonable doubt
and i'll tell you
you want to confuse a law student you
want to confuse lawyers and judges
you want to confuse jurors
tell them that the defendant must be
first of all presumed innocent
although one of the parties certainly
doesn't presume him innocent
right the prosecutor is is
is is uh
filing the case predicated on the idea
that they are guilty beyond a reasonable
doubt and that the jurors simply going
to agree
with the prosecutor
but telling jurors
and i just got finished teaching a jury
selection and decision making course
that i teach every fall
telling jurors that they must find the
defendant guilty beyond a reasonable
doubt and if they have a reasonable
doubt they must find the defendant
innocent is probably one of the most
confusing
epistemic
challenges
that
people will
face on a jury i think fortunately most
most speaking from experience
you know the vast majority of cases are
resolved by uh
um
the guilty plea
yeah which is any discussion between the
lawyers
well it depends i'm opposed to the whole
idea of guilty plea at all and uh as an
abolitionist i'm trying to come up with
the arguments to show that the criminal
justice system itself has too many flaws
and doesn't deliver justice and that a
civil justice system is better suited
but then there's a lot of niggling
details about how we deal with extremely
violent personnel and pre-trial
detention and so forth
but um
when it comes to
uh expecting jurors
to understand this uh uh standard
uh it's very difficult but most cases
resolve with the defendant's own
admission that they are guilty beyond a
reasonable doubt
through the plea bargain process a very
small percentage of cases go to trial
quite often they go to trial
uh because a defendant is obstinate
uh sometimes they go to trial because
the there's been no opportunity for plea
bargain and that happens in serious
cases
sometimes they go to trial because the
defendant
really is innocent
and if it were that obvious it is
unlikely that a prosecutor would persist
although there's plenty of black swans
and and uh
aberrations and of course exceptions
always end up proving the rule for
something like this
but it's a huge a huge burden
to place upon the community
to
to ask them to use this standard
of proof beyond a reasonable doubt
particularly one of the cases that i
just taught my class victor is the bill
cosby case
where
you've got a
and of course this is a somewhat
generational but you know for me growing
up bill cosby was
like o.j simpson
an entertainer who's much bigger
than
being a simple entertainer
and um
and that's from saturday morning tv
shows with bill cosby in the early 70s
to oj being in the movie theater i mean
these guys were
you know bigger than big and they were
wonderful uh men
well it turns out they're not
and
and
when oj was on trial
here's a person who's very well known
well loved with lots of money
bill cosby well known well loved with
lots of money and both are accused of
doing bad things
and how in the world is our jury system
supposed to be able to impartially
judge those those individuals and i
don't mean just them in particular
but
that is another
problem you know associated with
using jurors again is is what i like to
call
epistemic agents
who we are asking to
make these decisions you know the
european tradition our countries canada
and the us are some of the very few that
use the lay jury system
and in other nations um and certainly
with
uh prosecutions internationally like in
the international criminal court
uh
there's no lagery and how do you have a
lay jury
uh when you're charging uh
these banana republic dictators with
horrible crimes against humanity and
genocide
so um yeah i think ultimately i think
ultimately um
the questions that i'm trying to ask
is the question of abolition
and many of the
many of the angela davis the famous uh
african-american theorist
taught at san francisco state when i was
an undergrad there
and she wrote a wonderful very slim
little volume called our prisons
obsolete
and she maintains what i call you know
the activist uh
stance on on abolition which is
you know
uh united states is racism is racist
white supremacy therefore prison serves
white supremacy and there's a lot to be
said for that
but
what davis doesn't provide and what a
lot of the activists don't do and
and this is true for not just
activism in writing but also in
you know activism in the streets as well
is that there's there's not an
alternative that's being proposed and
davis actually at the end of her book
it's really fascinating
you know she gets to the end and she
goes well what do we replace it with we
obviously have a lot of a certain amount
of bad people doing bad things and one
explanation for it again would be
white supremacy
and
racial or uh income
disparity and so forth but that's not
going to cover every case at least i
don't think and i don't think she does
either
and she says maybe a pure a purely civil
uh system is the is the is the right
approach but she doesn't develop it
so i take a lot of inspiration from
davis and some of the other writers
about trying to come up with that
conceptual framework for
what these institutions might uh might
look like
and it's to present you know it's almost
science fiction it's almost uh
the creation of this um
you know new way of looking at criminal
justice and one which
uh
sees that urge to punish uh for what it
is which is kind of this
brutal
libidinal
uh urge
and reply and replace it with uh
what we might call more of a lust for
justice
yeah i um
one thought i had is
i don't know if you're familiar with the
norwegian system of i mean they still
have a criminal i mean everyone every
developed country has a criminal justice
system as far as i know at least i could
be wrong about that but i know that
norway their prison system was like
reformed in the 90s and i don't know how
much you know about it but they
kind of changed the philosophy to be we
want to simulate the outside world as
much as possible
in the in prisons
so you know they have a lot more freedom
there there's job programs there's like
a collaborative atmosphere between the
prison guards and the prisoners like
they
play games together they eat dinner
together they and and the outcomes have
been very promising i mean recidivism
rates went way down after that and and
people come out
much more equipped
so that seems like an uh an appealing
kind of stop gap maybe between or i mean
or maybe even something like that
because it seems to me there's probably
gonna always be some mechanism in the
very rare cases where somebody needs to
be
removed from society but that's like
one percent of one percent of one
percent of probably everybody who
interacts with the prison system but
yeah
well well sure you hit the nail on the
head the big question is at least for me
is what conditions have to
be satisfied to incapacitate a person
put them in a little a cage
and i think that those conditions are
rare
uh very and i'm saying this very
conceptually
slash
you know in the abstract that there are
very
few and pretty well specified
uh conditions that we could describe
that would therefore justify me grabbing
or anyone police doesn't matter
incapacitating a person you know the
word amok amok
is an indonesian word
and it refers to a phenomenon that would
occur in indonesia
when an individual you know this would
have i don't know
i'm painting a very broad brush with
this
but an individual would flip out with
their machete and start running around
and hacking you know people
and that was called you know a muck
so we call that now when we say you know
you look at a five-year-old and you're
like man that kid is running a month
well it's a real word
yeah interesting so what it means is
well what it means to the community you
start yelling a market it means go get
your machete
and we need to circle this guy and and
dispatch him so it's a little gory and
a little bit extreme
but it's kind of the same i'm i'm
intrigued by that
you know what
what conditions need to be present and
that's very
philos analytic philosophy sounding in
order for us to encircle you and take
you out of commission
either lethal force
uh or less than lethal
and and take you out of society and i
think there's very few certainly the
drugs and so forth
uh that doesn't meet those uh conditions
uh at all
but then that second uh big question is
is what do we do with you after that
and i think the argument the good
argument has not been made
that society then
is permitted or obligated
to
harm that individual
if you steal an apple
and we chase you down and we and we
grab the apple out of you and give it
back to the owner
you haven't been punished um and that's
an act of of restitution
and compensation
but then putting you in a little room
for
six months or a year or a week well
that's that's certainly
uh an act of punishment
yeah i like it i'm really uh you know
this i learned a lot i i didn't that
piece of the puzzle of like the civil
justice system
as kind of being uh you know something
that would exist in some form to address
a lot of things that are addressed in
the criminal justice system right now is
a really compelling idea to me at least
you know as someone who doesn't look at
maybe it's maybe it's like a kind of
obvious idea maybe not so so but anyway
so it's good i'm glad you brought that
to my attention because i've always kind
of pushed for a kind of abolitionism but
this kind of adds another piece of the
puzzle in my mind of how it would
work uh you know in a society after the
criminal justice system
so that's great i mean i think that's
well i mean there's more stuff i could
bring up but i don't want to keep you
for too long because we've already been
going for i think at least an hour and a
half so that's usually around the time
we go but if there's something you
wanted to add that'd be great too
uh one idea
that really held a lot of of interest
for me is the idea of restorative
uh justice
and
uh the the the key theory is
for that is an australian name
braithwaite
b r a b-r-a-i-t-h-w-a-i-t
and
he's been influenced by the justice
system of the aboriginal
people in
australia and new zealand
and their approach to
harms to individuals and communities
and there's been
a
you know
an influence
from those native communities in
the justice systems in those countries
and a little bit in the u.s
but
in my book i describe how i see a
connection with nietzsche as well
and it's based on this and i'll try to
sum it up really quickly restorative
justice wants to bring and the the the
the the bigger idea of restorative
justice wants to bring
wrongdoer and victim face to face
and there's a number of different
reasons for that and there some of them
are pragmatic and some of them are are
are are more much more emotional
and uh
many of them
many many of the justifications
try to serve that emotional need of the
victim
to express themselves
and our current criminal justice system
and when i say this my fellow defense
attorneys think i've you know become a
turncoat or something but
you know a person can
perceive a defendant through a criminal
case after committing unjust harms to
others maybe very serious
knowing that they have a very
uh imper
impermeable
barrier between them and the victim
society the family etc through the form
of the lawyer the judge etc
and i've stood next to many individuals
when they were sentenced with their back
to
persons that they have harmed and they
are then you know going to be
shuttled off to some house of correction
to pay for their crime so to speak
and the idea of restorative justice the
restorative justice is based around the
idea of the meeting
where
lawyers are not involved judges are not
involved and a
wrongdoer is sat down with their victim
with very little institutional or
normative guidance about what then
occurs
and what braithwaite uh braithwaite is
really the the main voice of this
approach to justice
you know describes a lot of uh anecdotal
evidence and epidemiological evidence if
that's the right word
i don't think i've ever used the word
before but you know studies etc of what
occurs um
at some of the meetings
and you know you might have a
a person whose home has been invaded by
two kids and they they ripped up their
family photos and
you know the victim uh hits them
you know shame on you for doing this to
my family pictures
and you know in many ways
being forced to confront your victim
is probably you know we go back to
discussions with my clients over the
years you know my guess is the last
thing in the world a person who is
harmed another person wants to do is
really be confronted by them
and uh you know they know that the
criminal justice system through the
constitution and all the the protections
of the defendant
uh will will attempt to maintain this
this
this
impermeable again impermeable barrier
between the wrongdoer and
their victim and in many ways the victim
is very much a secondary in our
contemporary criminal justice system
like in the uh in the rittenhouse case
the judge this was a big big hit all the
all the news sources
the judge had told the prosecutor not to
refer
to the decedents those are the the dead
dead people who died and then the other
individual who was shot
as victims
and of course it hit all the headlines
and i had several people ask me what the
hell is going on
it's absolutely normal
every criminal case where you've got a
person who
you know is harmed by another and is
coming to court to
complain about it i know that i don't
mean complain like normal it means
it's a technical term
right
they are really the complaining
witness
and so anytime
you have a jury trial the defense
attorney
whether they're paid by these right-wing
nuts or whatever that
you know
provided the council for written house
or not
your job is to before court say your
honor i'm asking that you
tell the prosecutor
not to refer to
tom dick and harry or whatever as
victims they're not victims until there
is a
conviction
a good judge
will say you're right don't do it other
judges will say i'm not going to do it
so there's not a
it's not a constitutional issue if a
judge allows them you're not going to
win on an appeal and go to the supreme
court and do all that
but a good judge will say
yeah don't call them victims but then
man that hit the press and suddenly this
judge
you know is this right winger
uh racist who's buddy buddy with
with rittenhouse then a couple days
later they're watching a video and the
written house got behind the judge a
judge got behind written house to watch
a video and it looked like they were
posing for a picture together and that's
how it was
explained in the media anyway there was
yeah there was a lot of mis like
misinformation about like a lot of
people chiming in and commenting about
stuff that they had no idea about how
like legal procedures work and were
making assumptions that this was some
kind of travesty when they themselves
had no idea how it normally works and
yeah that was definitely the key example
the thing about victims
um but when you look it's pretty normal
uh except to do that yeah that was an
interesting one the whole case was
you know it seemed to me
to be an interesting example of where a
lot of really really smart people
like became like kind of like
intellectually deranged
in a way i don't know maybe that's like
a too unkind of a thing to say but it
just seemed like people were incapable
of just like doing a cursory
investigation about how these things
work
to see that it's like not what it
appears and it was just really funny to
see how many people
like just everybody like nobody was
seeing this
uh i mean i don't want to claim that i
had some objective
perspective on things but i don't know i
just like took 10 minutes to look into
how these legal proceedings work and
then
you know you realize it's not as biased
and terrible as you think it is so well
he's going to get hit with a civil case
he's going to get sued that's true
and
there's there's that different standard
of proof
so i think the jurors all 12 of them
watched the video listened to the
the testimony and said i have a doubt in
my mind of whether this guy went out
there
and purposefully killed these peaceful
protesters and that he had a reasonable
belief in his uh
you know own personal safety
so
whether that's right or wrong hopefully
it's it's right and hopefully you know
what the jury did was the right thing
but i hope and i urge every the family
member and
of the decedents to sue him
and if a jury decides that he's liable
civilly liable and that there is no
self-defense from a civil perspective
that they get a judgment against him and
that our our civil system can try to
find
you know some some justice for
uh what what
you know
what seemed
i was about to say clearly but that's
that's that's a tough word what seemed
to be people who've been unjustly harmed
or wronged uh by
uh by written house
yeah
yeah i mean i watched all the videos and
i think my opinion was i probably would
have found
reasonable doubt
myself
so i wasn't surprised by the verdict at
all
but yeah the civil case is obviously a
different matter so
well what surprised me
if you just kind of watch the new york
times headlines and
we all
watched our
the news sources that we trust
um then that's obviously a big problem
as well
this guy just randomly went down there
and started taking pot shots at people
who i think most of us would think are
there to protest the shooting of of
jacob blake right
than to support blm and to do other
things that i've got my own affinities
with
uh but the facts especially is preserved
on all these different
uh
videos
you know is that there was this
substantial presence of these
oath keeper i don't know what they are
you know not not my kind of people
whatsoever
uh but there had been two nights of
rioting where whole city blocks had been
burned up
uh
there was a uh what's the right word
here
whatever the mood was there
um it was a very bad scene all around
and um
i think the footage shows orlando desire
i would say
yeah yeah well
you know um when you believe that police
are acting
in a murderous
murderously racially discriminatory way
you want to go out and you want to
confront them and you want them to stop
and
whether those techniques have worked
that's a whole different discussion
[Music]
but yeah i'd even leading up to the
trial i thought
i think they're going to acquit him i
think they're going to look at this and
see him being chased by the first
uh victim i can't think of a better word
and then
him falling down and the guy point
pointing a gun at him
so yeah
i have a hard time saying it's justified
um
because i don't want to
justify or support
people showing up with guns and running
around like that at the same time
saying that the evidence looks like
there's a reasonable doubt based on our
pro our current legal standard
about his guilt is is quite another so i
don't want to justify
it i don't think anybody has justified
it except for his right and far-right
supporters
but um
yeah it ended up being a tough
discussion with some people where i said
i think uh this was the right verdict
and i anticipated it and there were the
response for many of people i discussed
it with was oh well that's because of
white supremacy and my response is
no i don't think that that's not why and
it's not because it's it's open season
on killing uh blm
supporters or uh protesters
you imagine being on that jury that's
pretty tough isn't it exactly i mean
that's kind of an example of that sort
of like intellectual derangement that i
was talking about but yeah we should uh
we should probably wrap the wrap this up
i think um
yeah good you want to do like a final
question or uh
well i was just gonna say that you know
prof uh associate professor blake wilson
at uh the
uh state university or it's california
state university stanislas and actually
i forgot to mention in the introduction
that you actually have what looks to be
a very interesting edited volume because
i'm a fan
of uh werner herzog the philosophy of
werner herzba herzog co-edited and i
think probably some of our listeners
might be a fan as well so that's
interesting i meant to ask you about
that but we kind of got
into the weeds and maybe if we talk
again in the future i'd love to also
prod slash challenge you about um
your support of the second amendment
which i think you mentioned at the
beginning but you know we've we've gone
for quite a long time so i don't want to
pull us into something new but thanks a
lot for coming i really enjoyed the
conversation yeah well thanks victor
it's great to chat with you and um
i do have a website which is m
blakewilson.com
and some of my writing and works
available there
and yes one year ago my colleague in the
philosophy department at cal state
stanislaus and that's the the college is
named after the county
and the county seat is modesto
and it's between
fresno and sacramento out in the central
valley
but chris and i put together chris
turner and i put together the philosophy
of werner herzog and it was a
a way
to be able to satisfy my publishing
obligations for my job
and to explore
you know somebody who's been one of my
favorite filmmakers for a long time so
it was great to talk to you take care
and i hope to see you soon and stay safe
out there yeah thanks
thanks so much
[Music]
you